(upbeat music)
- Cross-stitch for rappers,
are you joking?
I'm an anomaly in this scene, for sure.
I'm Emma McKee, and I'm
a cross-stitch artist.
I create custom, one-of-a-kind
cross-stitch jackets
for Chicago's creative class.
(upbeat music)
Cross-stitch is a
antiquated form of stitching
traditionally done by your grandma.
I fell backwards into it.
I made a present for my
mom a couple years ago,
so I taught myself how to cross-stitch.
It came very naturally to me,
and so
I decided to do more.
I felt compelled to do it,
but I didn't know what to do it for.
But then, the obvious connection was,
well, I'll do it for the
things that inspire me.
And the things that I loved
were art, and poetry, and music.
♪ We do the ♪
♪ We don't do the same drugs ♪
- Chance the Rapper is like the
prince of Chicago, you know?
He's Chicago royalty.
Chance is one of my favorite rappers,
and so I
made this jacket.
It was a three jacket,
it was Chance's three.
And I was like, okay,
I'll put this on Twitter.
We'll see what this does.
Like 30 seconds later,
(phone chiming)
Chance the Rapper
has followed you, Chance the
Rapper has sent you a DM.
I mean, he's like, “Yo,
how do I get this?"
And I was like, any way
you want, Chance (laughs).
And he wore it on the cover of Billboard,
and that was kinda like how it started.
(draw scraping)
This, a-ha,
is for an artist named McJenkins.
It's a heart.
(upbeat music)
I've made something like 135
pieces in the last four years.
Some of the people I've made stuff for,
SZA, Major Lazer,
Chance the Rapper, Vic Mensa,
Most Def,
Joey Purp,
Kendrick Lamar.
Oh, yeah, Lil Yachty, of course.
How could I forget about Lil Yachty?
But, the majority of
them are worn by people
who are not famous.
A lot of the people I
make stuff for in Chicago
wear their stuff every day.
Live in the things.
Cross-stitch is just a cross, stitched.
It's just a square.
You basically take an image,
and you pixelate the hell out of it.
So you map out a bunch of tiny squares.
It takes very good spacial recognition,
a lot of patience, and
you cannot mess it up.
My inspiration usually will come
complete, finished,
everything, from a person.
It arrives in my head fully
formed, and that's it.
I have no idea how we get there,
I don't sit around and
think about it for somebody.
Like, the way that I'm able
to make something for somebody
is if it is there.
(violin music)
I have to go out to the
suburbs to buy my thread.
It's all specialty.
I spend an ungodly amount
of money on thread,
it would freak you out.
(register beeping and rattling)
I always say the median
amount of time in a jacket
is anywhere from like, 50 to 60 hours.
When you're done, then you
get to pull the graph out.
And then you get to see
what it looks like when it's finished.
(birds chirping)
People call what's happening
(upbeat music)
in Chicago a renaissance.
We have art, and we have music,
and we have all these people
making positive changes.
All these people making
incredible, incredible stuff.
I have a team that oscillates
anywhere from seven to 14 people,
and they're all artists, they're
all other Chicago artists.
And we do these big
photo shoots with people.
But it's like really the only
way that I catalog anything,
is by having pictures of it.
- It is.
- I like those a lot.
The giving away part is the best part.
To see something that
you've made affect somebody
in what seems to be a meaningful way
is a pretty emotional thing.
(upbeat music)
The goal with the cross-stitch jackets
was never to sell them or
to make money off of them.
It's truly, truly a passion project.
I'm not Gucci, I'm just, you know,
I'm Stitch Gawd.
(upbeat tone)